hey what is up guys mkbhd here and a lot
of smartphones come out every single
year right and 2014 was clearly no
exception to that rule so with the
holidays coming up and beyond uh there
are a lot of different options to choose
from a lot of different choices to make
your daily driver so this video is your
one stop shop for picking one this will
hopefully give you the best option to
choose for your phone for the next two
years to sign a contract with so of all
the smartphones that were released into
the world in 2014 these are the best
options from each category and i'm not
just going to give a best i'm going to
give a first place so generally the best
option a second place so sort of a
runner-up still really good and an
honorable mention or two so also some
really good options even though they're
not first place worthy of consideration
so of all the stuff we've seen come out
in the last 300 something days these are
the smartphone awards 2014.
so the first category is big phones and
we've seen a lot of huge phones released
over the course of the year they keep
getting bigger every single year i
hesitate to use the word phablet because
even the definition of that word changes
from year to year but these are the best
big phones and your first
best option is the samsung galaxy note
4. the note 4 is an awesome phone it has
a 5.7 inch quad hd amoled display that
i'd say is arguably the best in any
smartphone right now it has a massive
battery a really good battery life an
excellent camera beastly specs and
performance and it's the one that's
actually best at taking advantage of
being so big with the software say what
you want about touchwiz but its
multitasking capabilities on top of
android 4.4 and hopefully lollipop soon
are second to none it has a ton of
features that use the entire display and
it has a stylus that s pen for even more
multitasking fun so overall the best
large phone experience is with the note
4 and if you're going to go huge you
might as well go all the way the second
best option i'll give for a really big
phone to consider this year is the
iphone 6 plus it's the first huge iphone
that apple has put out it has a 5.5 inch
display which is like barely making the
cut for huge phones but it counts it's
the biggest i've ever made and it's
really good my honorable mention for a
huge phone is going to go to the nexus 6
which has a 5.9 inch quad hd display and
also worth mentioning is the samsung
galaxy s5 it's not quite as huge as the
other ones we've talked about but the
nexus 6 is running stock android it's a
pure google experience phone it's going
to be first in line for updates all the
typical pros of being a nexus device
again all the reviews i'll have of all
the devices i talk about in this video
will be linked right below that like
button if you want to check them out and
the samsung galaxy s5 it's a standard
samsung flagship even though the note i
think is a clearly better phone in a lot
of ways there are a lot of things to
like about the galaxy s5 in a not quite
as massive package also i want to
mention one more the lg g3 i put it in
the big phones category as it has a 5.5
inch display but it's the one that
actually doesn't have a huge feel in the
hand it does a great job of not feeling
really big with these thinner bezels and
nice design so worth considering as a
big phone now speaking of and not quite
as massive package uh
this is the next category which is
compact phones the best compact phones
released in 2014 and by far and away the
best option here is the sony xperia z3
compact it fits in a tiny footprint and
this is the little brother to the larger
sony xperia z3 but it makes almost no
trade-offs or compromises when moving
down to the smaller size which is what
compact phone lovers really want so it
has excellent specs and performance with
the snapdragon 801 and 2gigs of ram it
has a 20 megapixel sony camera which is
of course excellent in typical sony
fashion and it has a 4.6 inch 720p
display on the front which is great and
yes by today's standards that does make
it compact
you're packing a 2600 milliamp hour
battery with quick charging technology
front-facing speakers and it's ip68
certified so there's a lot going on in
this little package and it is on top of
its game right now for the second best
compact phone of the year i'm gonna give
that to the samsung galaxy alpha which
is essentially a miniature version of
the galaxy note 4 which is the best
large phone of the year so there's not a
lot to dislike about the galaxy alpha
it's compact it's well built it has
metal everywhere of course that's what
it's known for
plus it has a great display and again
high-end internals and nice specs in a
small phone it's really what small phone
lovers want in a nutshell so my
honorable mention for compact phones is
the iphone 6 and although i like the
iphone 6 plus better in basically every
way it has more space inside for a
larger battery and optical image
stabilization and various other things
but the iphone 6 is still a great phone
and for people who don't want to move up
to a huge phone the three that i've
listed here are excellent options if you
still like to one-handed text if you
still like to use your phone all the
time with one hand if you still put it
in your front pocket and you don't like
the huge phones sticking out the front
these options you can't really go wrong
so this next category is for your
photographers who like to take pictures
or photos on your smartphone all the
time these are the best smartphone
cameras out there or really the best
cameras that also happen to be a part of
a smartphone and i'm going to give the
first best option to the iphone 6 plus
and the second best option to the
samsung galaxy note 4. and i mentioned
these at the same time because they're
so very similar in a lot of ways if you
focus a lot on photos i'll give the edge
to the iphone 6 plus but if you focus a
lot on videos i'll give the edge to the
galaxy note 4. so the iphone 6 plus gets
the edge in the photo department for its
superior image processing and optical
image stabilization and it also has a
relatively large sensor and pixel size
so while it's just an 8 megapixel camera
that does mean it has really good low
light performance it also happens to be
ridiculously fast even taking hdr shots
and overall it produces some of the most
pleasing and most accurate colors from
any smartphone camera i've ever seen
unfortunately 8 megapixels does limit it
in the video department to 1080p and
that's where the galaxy note 4 steps in
so if you take a lot of video on your
smartphone and if you absolutely must
have the best of the best the note 4 is
the clear choice shooting 4k video from
a 16 megapixel sensor which is super
sharp and crispy and colorful and
beautiful it also has optical image
stabilization and takes great photos too
just a very different character
altogether the note 4 photos tend to be
much more saturated and sharpened than
normal while you may or may not like
that it is definitely the clear winner
here for video now after the top five or
so smartphone cameras do tend to
deteriorate very quickly but i'll give
an honorable mention to the sony xperia
z3 sony we already know does excellent
smartphone camera optics and this z3 is
no exception it's a 20 megapixel camera
like the xperia z3 compact i talked
about and it takes excellent photos as
well and does happen to be capable of 4k
video again so if you're in the market
for a smartphone camera or a camera that
takes really good pictures and also
happens to be attached to a smartphone
those are your three best options now
let's be honest a lot of the phones
we're talking about here are basically
super phones they have all the high-end
specs they're essentially the best of
what these manufacturers have to offer
and that's why they're winning awards as
they have all these high-end parts but
they often cost a lot of money on or off
contract but sometimes you want a new
smartphone and you don't want it to cost
an arm and a leg especially during the
holiday season you might want to get a
nice inexpensive phone that's still
really good so i'll consider under 400
bucks off contract the best budget
smartphones of the year for 2014 and my
easy easy hands down first place choice
is the one plus one now the thing about
the oneplus one i mean it's an excellent
phone in basically every way the build
quality is great the camera is really
good the display is really good it's a
fast performer the software is excellent
the battery life is incredible it's
going to be first in line for updates
when cyanogenmod gets to this thing so
it's a really really good phone in a lot
of ways and for 16 gigs 350 bucks it's a
no-brainer but the thing is you can't
really buy it yet i reviewed this thing
months ago and it's still really
difficult to place an order and just get
this phone without going through some
convoluted invite system or something
like that so if you don't want to have
to wait to try to get this thing you
don't have to jump through hoops the
second best option is your moto g 2014.
sort of like the little brother to the
new moto x with a stock android
experience and a front-facing speaker
again and not awful camera and super
inexpensive game changing at 180 bucks i
also have to give an honorable mention
to
the nexus 5 it wasn't released this year
technically it's a 2013 release but it's
basically still right now it's also
under 400 bucks and it's a really good
phone again you're gonna get essentially
first in line for software updates uh
for at least the next year or two and i
think this would not be a bad phone at
all to sign a contract with for two
years but you probably don't have to
because it's a nice easy budget phone so
nexus 5 is worth considering just for
that now i want to give out a couple
specialty awards because there are some
noteworthy phones that would not have
otherwise been mentioned in these top
categories
the first one i want to mention is a
most improved award and this one might
come as a bit of surprise for people who
have seen my videos or watched me for
more than a couple of months but i'm
getting the most improved award for 2014
to a blackberry and it's not just
because it's red and black but this is
the blackberry passport now i still
wouldn't use a blackberry daily it's not
that good yet and that's actually a big
reason i haven't reviewed it in detail
is because every phone i review i use as
a daily driver but despite its weird
looks turns out the passport has gotten
a lot better in the software department
i'm not saying a 4.5 inch square display
is just what this company needs but with
three gigs of ram and a snapdragon 801
and a 3400mah battery and a new
refreshed os in blackberry 10 it was
actually very smooth and pretty fun to
use now the next specialty award i want
to give is for best windows phone now i
haven't reviewed a lot of windows phone
devices this year but people should know
that there are a lot of good windows
mobile devices out there if you happen
to love a microsoft surface or you're
really invested in the microsoft windows
ecosystem windows 8 or windows 10 then
you're going to like a windows phone
probably and i'm going to give that
first place award or the only award for
best windows phone to the htc one m8 for
windows phone i also want to give an
honorable mention in that category to
the nokia lumia 735 it also is sort of a
really good budget smartphone so it's
sort of straddling those categories but
it's a really good pick either way i
also want to give an award for craziest
phone design that i saw personally this
year and i'm going to give that to this
little guy the sharp aquos crystal i did
a video on all about why i think
smartphone manufacturers in general
should take more design risks and try to
mix it up like this and sharp with this
budget offering kind of took it to the
next level with this basically zero
bezel display or one bezel on the bottom
in the form of a massive chin and it
really feels like a super compact phone
but believe it or not it actually has a
five inch display packed in here so it's
this tiny footprint i thought it was
really interesting to see and you should
definitely watch the full review of this
guy it'll be linked below now i also
have to give out a bust of the year i
have to give out an award for the worst
phone that i saw really uh it wasn't a
very good phone in any way there was no
real reason for people to buy it there
wasn't really anything good that
separated it for its price from the pack
it just didn't really have anything
going for it it's not even in front of
me it's the amazon fire phone uh i don't
even want to say anything more than that
if you want to check out the video i did
on it when it was first announced and i
go over the features of it and what it
is and it costs 650 but i think amazon's
gonna learn its lesson from this one and
probably stick to the kindles if it
comes out with another fire phone i'll
be very curious to see what they change
but uh yeah i'll leave a link to that
video in an annotation or below it's uh
it's the bust of the year it wasn't
really gonna hit anything good for
amazon so the best of the best this is
the last category phone of the year for
2014. best phone to come out during the
year 2014 and there are a lot of really
good options i could name probably three
random phones on this table and they'd
all be good but my first place for best
phone and this is an again it's an
opinion it's one person saying what my
favorite phone is but my best favorite
phone of the year for 2014 is gonna go
to the htc one m8 this is an all-around
winner from htc this year an improvement
in almost every way from the m7 of last
year as it should be and it really got
the build quality discussion going for
almost every phone that came out after
it samsung started putting metal in
their phones after the one 1m8 apple
came out with two all-metal iphones
after the 1m8 this phone single-handedly
got people talking about build quality
just as much as any other smartphone
feature the only thing is it's a little
bit slippery since it has these rounded
metal sides so i opted to put this
carbon fiber skin on the back of mine to
help with grip and i'm also rocking the
google play edition version of this
phone that's available that's another
huge reason why i like this phone so
much and if you look at the long list of
phones that i had my main sim card in
during 2014 the google play edition 1m8
was my daily for the longest duration
for most of the year i could come back
to this phone after using anything else
just to come back to the ridiculously
fast solidly built boom sound wielding
sharp bright long lasting smartphone
that this is i'm highly satisfied
highly recommended if you get this zone
you're probably not going to regret it
now my second place and it's a very
close second place for my favorite phone
to come out this year during 2014 is the
moto x the moto x 2014 continues from
the legacy of one of my favorites of
last year which was the 2013 moto x and
it's still really good in a lot of ways
it's one of the best built phones of the
year thanks to the added metal band
around the whole thing and it continues
motorola's strategy of delivering a near
stock android experience with a few
tweaks and additions here and there in
order to keep up with the fast os
updates in fact this phone is one of the
few with android 5.0 lollipop already
and it's a great performer just so easy
to recommend for first-time android
users just like its predecessor was uh
the learning curve for a lot of its
features are super minimal unlike maybe
some samsung or lg features that take a
while to learn that are less useful
and this moto x also gave birth to the
nexus 6 a few months later so we can
give it props for that and uh just gotta
love that dimple i like this one a lot
i'm gonna give my third place honorable
mentions i have two of them actually in
this category for best phone of the year
and those are gonna go to the iphone 6
and the lg g3 the iphone 6 i hesitate to
put because i like the iphone 6 plus
that much more but the iphone 6 is an
excellent all-around phone and it still
tends to be one of those that i
recommend to people a lot if you're just
getting into smartphones or if it's
someone's first smartphone if it's mom
buying a smartphone and she has a budget
to work with i tend to recommend the
iphone 6 and it's one of the best
iphones yet despite the fact that it's
so thin and the battery is so small
still really good uh and the lg g3
because it was one of the earliest to
have that quad hd display i love the
design of it as well uh with the very
thin bezels on the top left and right
again an excellent design and a pretty
solid phone again in a lot of ways so
you can't really go wrong with any of
the phones on this list again the moto x
awesome the htc one m8 really good the
iphone 6
and the lg g3 can't really go wrong
there
and those are my phones of the year best
of 2014. so moral of the story
there are a lot of great phones to
choose from this year whether you're
into a large phone or a particularly
small one or you're working with a
budget or you love taking pictures or
cameras whatever it is
you can't really go wrong with any of
the ones here so uh best of luck weigh
the pros and cons you'll probably be
happy with what you pick
also share this video with people who
you think are in the midst of buying a
smartphone right now it'll probably save
you a lot of time and explaining
thank you for watching this video and
i'll talk to you guys in the next one
peace